orientation is locked what it looks like
it's working is it the icons are
flipping what's up party people sup
party people we don't read comments
sideways today yeah are we should I flip
the camera just like this alright hey
hey guys
dudes hello really sick right now so I
told John just to come to my room and
well yeah yeah yeah Mario like I'll just
just stop what I'm doing right now we're
gonna do a reaction which pear right now
I am feeling pretty sick and as China
comes to the bedroom this doesn't want
to do a livestream what we shot movie
news thing for patreon from my bedroom
yeah I wanted to watch a regain now yeah
it was a decision we made that's why
it's a sin right that's the way the
world thinks stupidly okay so I wanted
to watch debt no I actually quiets the
bigger reason why I came on here I
wanted to watch death cure but I'm only
gonna be on here for like five minutes
guys I'm just not with honey I was were
anytime I get a little sick I'm like oh
my god is it that flu I don't think it's
the flu how crazy would it be if it was
that flu I heard even would the flu shot
you can't prevent it
I mean it just makes it less shitty when
you do get it but yeah maybe if I'm
feeling better tomorrow I'll go watch
Maze Runner but I want to buddy I
actually didn't want to see it but guys
since we're on here for like five
minutes let's do a speed round of
questions and answers for you guys speed
round we can't take along on any answer
hello to Russia rogue loves you guys
Thanks l saw little girl walk behind
them oh yeah John and I adopted we have
a lot of ghosts in this house
what's undone what's until dawn who
would be a best fit actor for a carnage
movie Oh Topher Grace I think you just
play all the seven symbiont Eddie Murphy
so diabetes is not okay I agree what
movie are you most looking forward to
Mandy with Nicolas Cage III would have
to say this year would be [ __ ] what the
hell's coming out this year first thing
that comes to mind is infinity war
that's got to be my number one most
anticipated right now oh yeah whenever
my cats go to the window there's always
a neighbor who just goes up to the cat
and goes yeah it's never led to
conversations I heard the Deadpool
trailers dropping on Valentine's Day
that's gonna make my girlfriend happy do
you guys smoke the magic grass I smoked
it once a year on top of a mountain
really really big wish I'm looking
forward to a solo Star Wars movie Oh
guys I'm telling you right now I am NOT
looking forward to solo you know what I
was thinking I've been watching Cowboy
Bebop
lately and I was thinking damn solo
would have been a cool Star Wars show if
anything I feel like that would have
been the only way we could accept a
reboot at Han Solo please me either way
even if even
solo the movie has this like Cowboy
Bebop 5 I think that'd be really cool
I like 90s hip-hop sure sure why not
you know Westside Connection the world
belongs to us better damn before I call
me your 10 favorite TV show ever
Breaking Bad and Friends Cowboy Bebop
live action show that'd be cool who
would be you're casting for it chapter 2
I would replace the floor for white
maybe Jason Clarke in there somewhere
you know got the same predictions for
Game of Thrones 2018 I think Daenerys is
gonna be pregnant and it's gonna be what
Jon Snow's baby and no one's gonna give
a [ __ ] when it happens favorite Maze
Runner book considering I've read all
three I'm gonna go with the second one
was it she's not on the biscuit because
you gotta go to Taco Bell and get them
to combine for you I just live streams
make me feel a little better
have I seen all the episodes no I
haven't seen all the episodes of any
talk show Brady Jorgensen actually asked
a great question would you rather smoke
weed with Snoop Dogg or cocaine with
Eminem I feel like I would have a better
conversation with Eminem and I feel like
I'm likely to get in a fight with him if
he has go and my fight I mean he would
do coke and then start rap insulting me
and I would kill myself that is more
cocaine and jump off a building
snoop dogg look I just don't understand
your world I don't relate with Snoop
Dogg lyrics
oh hey Frank Sedita asked have you guys
seen the new nacho fries to talk about
yet not yet but I want to get one today
but I don't know if yo did I keep seeing
so many comments are coming in I keep
seeing something for this until dawn
death scenes I just I don't know I feel
like when I watch a video game trailer I
feel so pressured to play the game and
then I feel terrible for never getting
around to at least four trailer
reactions we'll we'll watch 1 out of
every 10 tree goatee boy Gary says most
underrated movie of 2017 that would have
to be tragedy girls for me would you
rather have fingers the same size as
your legs or have legs they would have
to be okay for sure it would have to be
the fingers the same size as my legs
because you know who's gonna be some
freaky woman out there who's gonna be
like yeah just stick it in and if you
have your legs you could still hump if
they just want pennis would you rather
spend a day with Heath Ledger's Jared
Jared Leto's true but either of those is
gonna be a good day he played I have
straight in my hair you should check out
the video I did on someone's channel go
back to Halloween I am half asian my
favorite video game is Megaman X
yourself or commit suicide oh-ho-ho the
options I love people who don't like us
who hop in on
yeah because they clearly have so much
time they'll be like quit wasting your
time I'll be like you might think we're
wasting our time
but if we're gonna play a game of who's
wasting more time video with Jeremy jaws
or John Flixster well I've made a cameo
and a flick serve log and flick sir made
a cameo in one of my vlogs and I've
collab with flicks through videos I
would love to do one with John's I feel
like I'd be so nervous the whole time
although one of my favorite YouTube
experiences we did an interview on Josh
mokuba's show and they actually cut out
the part that I was talking about
because it was his way to nasty and
raunchy but I remember when Jeremy Jones
was watching something like three people
watching and Jeremy Jones was one of
people watching Jeremy cobster and and
he started and then he started and
Jeremy started dying of laughter out or
something I was saying and he like
clapped his hands and pointed at me and
that was like one of my favorite YouTube
moments
would you rather Greg John or John
should I wait for my wife to finish
season 2 of strangers sure what so you
wait for her like [ __ ] hurry up play
that [ __ ] fast-forward they head off the
show favorite DreamWorks Animation would
be Ice Age 3 short tale favorite Martin
Scorsese
I would say you know everyone says
Goodfellas I mean there's a clap I think
no one ever says the part is shutter
island' but I grew up on Goodfellas and
I grew up on Raging Bull I
those are films i watch repetitively
growing up the departed doubt to me is
my favorite Scorsese film I know that's
not a popular opinion but I got stick to
my guns and thoughts on nostalgia critic
he's [ __ ] hysterical would you rather
give up your legs or give up the
Internet look at a book chase Larson's
been subscribed to us for two years
favorite Tarantino movie probably Django
yeah I know it's not Paul fiction or
reservoir I haven't seen mom and dad yet
is that because that guy is that out
sugar Islands pretty underrated but I
don't wondering even call one of my
favorites all that love came here though
I think Cape Fear is one of the
Scorsese's best hate fears legit and I'm
actually really looking accommodating
Tyler you know Toy Story 2 was better
than Toy Story 1 in my personal opinion
well Incredibles to be as good as the
first I have no idea none because
there's nothing to go off but the first
one goes back to the future I'm a big
Back to the Future that's a good point
that departed I mean I want to call it a
stolen film date and everyone knows it's
like not like one of those Aronofsky's
situations where they're like this is an
exact movie of another one
hdhd are filthy Frank ooh both so good
alligator eh three a lot two favorite
musicians are Chili Peppers and mmm what
would you rather watch monsters inc or
wall-e
spoon Monsters Inc wall-e
yeah I do remember my name is roll
Sicario hell or high water Wind River I
would go Sicario I haven't seen one
river though yeah I know I'm a dick
Batman V Superman or civil war Civil War
well louis c.k come back now he I don't
know
not anytime soon Abdullah Buddha they
tryna jacked over here
my favorite antihero is Ryan Gosling and
drive that's on the air oh I have to
watch the last couple episodes but I
think the season is gonna be getting
really good right about now lately I
haven't been loving it but I think it's
gonna start really getting good when you
when you're gonna see another video with
you and Tyrone Magnus
whenever he's in LA or in the East Coast
Tyrone doesn't like me anymore okay a
girl's been watching this for two years
camera bay bloody real person or is this
one of those like I can't tell because
that sound like a thing I bought would
comment camera names camera Babli I
really like beautiful this is my least
favorite
beautiful and I really do love [ __ ]
I do love not afraid but actually the
legacy from lp2 is pretty bomb album - I
haven't seen legends tomorrow or Gotham
know I haven't seen latest tomorrow
season two or three and I can't get into
Gotham try oh we meet is Greg LaVon
markiplier now a man I began that
comment four years huh Justice League or
Watchmen Justice League camera BAE
bloody yeah oh I kind of stole it from
well thanks for being here okay thanks
for being a real human being is that
your profile though are you a guy who
stole your female friends who are you
what are you gay you guys make a cute
couple
thanks Don I love I love our YouTube
comments because it's a combination of
you guys are so cute together to being
gay insults inside or supportive or
hatred yeah well you're a pretty girl
camera babe I'm assuming that's your
real name
you guys buds no we we're part of a
studio that pairs people actors we're
supposed to be we're supposed to be best
buds yeah do you guys think earthing
heist is gonna be trash because it looks
shitty as [ __ ] yes
hurricane ice rather do vids on just
reactions on youtube vids what or just
movies and trailer reactions and reviews
I prefer trailers I prefer trailers
reviews I do but the YouTube ones we do
like Swiss Re man oh that movie was
awesome I loved that movie
it made me it touched me and all the
weirdest most wonderful ways I recommend
this guys so they're not gay
Wayne Wayne the East Coast quiz is
probably like clockwork camera babe say
never doubted my sex do we say something
oh yeah we asked if she was a dude
borrowing somebody's account yeah no
it's just you you're obviously a pretty
female so we didn't know if you were you
know if you were fake I did see the
first episode of American Gods have been
dying to continue it was great
damn some ASSA didn't know you are gay
you know yeah well copper spa Roman
Blake dude we got you through tough
times you got us through tough times oh
because you watch the videos if we can't
get anyone through tough times oh man
tough times after your reaction what are
your thoughts on mom and dad before it
comes out I really want to see it I
really want to see it
Haley P says we do the best reactions on
YouTube you know what's weird
I go to Tyrone Magnus's channel and some
people say he does the best then I go to
blind waves and they say he does the
best then I go to javi Kuwait and some
people say he does the best there's no
real way of determining no mathematical
rubric who is it really just based off
the most authentic like what here we go
it up well apparently all my reactions
are fake so do you John all your
reactions are fake no stop reacting so
much like it's a reaction video Matt the
fake yeah man yes like a few times he's
benched us
favorite MCU movie Thor the dark world
The Incredible Hulk I would probably go
with Civil War first Iron Man first
youtube video ever watch is definitely a
Jeremy John's review
it's probably like a bo burnham thing no
I'm not hi I'm sick but the live shows
are making me feel a little better cuz
I've been it's distracting me I was
gonna go watch Not Call Me watch The
Maze Runner the depth cure but I've just
like went to bed last night with a
really high fever Fernando Botero
Magnus's reactions are not fake I will
defend Tyrone Magnus what's happening is
Tyrone does a lot of drugs before he
films a reaction so what you're seeing
is a result of being really high on
numerous amounts of drugs and that is in
a itself authentic reaction in that
moment death cure is good but so many
emotions I'm not really for x-men being
in the MCU but sure why not ain't gonna
change my life yeah yeah we're dating we
should just go with the gay thing or
Channel might blow up yeah you know we
are actually the 3rd identity revealed
yeah and now we don't have different
names people its sexuality is a spectrum
we should all embrace that much happier
I wanted to see good times so bad and I
missed a video I think we should do a
Edward Cullen spin-off yeah well they
wrote the book from his point of view oh
god don't offend Tyrone er he
come and react I just imagine when you
said that I just imagined like a Super
Smash Brothers style thing but all
reactions based and everybody else like
a signature moves like Tyrone signature
punches like a 1 million subscriber hand
like John it's your number one horny fan
page project and over mirrors forever be
known as that guys if you ever see Ana
Ramirez Greg isn't gay but his boyfriend
is you're my boyfriend
if you ever see Ana Ramirez go oh you're
that girl who's always horny for John
just like that she unpledged from the
patriarchy
I don't know they pledged because of our
personalities I think I don't know I
don't even know why people watch us and
great night now I just open up a whole
can of comments I just said I don't know
if you watches
well you're labeling rejects and your
two men clean next to each other
we're not cuddling guys we have right
here this is meeting your father Lee all
right this this is I'm sick and I asked
John to come to the bed so I can do this
he reacts
hey who's be reacts dude she must have a
reaction channel let's end the
livestream and just go to Hershey you
know I have not seen the Brazil
comic-con venom reveal now dude raka
raka I saw their Instagram recently man
their channel has been getting hit hard
you can't swing going down a lot because
of the content my favorite comments are
the ones who are like your channel
channels dying I'm like even she knows
to like most channels and I yeah you
know every channel is kind of depending
on like a couple of really great videos
a month right now you need like three
affinities war a month how do you
maintain your hair just Olivia Olivia
come over oh yeah I'm so my friend rode
corn hub
what's your port half channel called I
am busy I'm doing a live come over you
have the keys we were supposed to do a
Google hangout with Diego shy Dez but he
never got back to us yeah there's still
an invitation waiting out there I had it
at a whole Linkin Park reaction dude I'm
Dante's been blowing up he does those
music video things I wasn't caught baby
just come over
keeping the reaction catalysed to keep
doing your thing people are soon their
action moves diving we need to prove
them wrong
well you know the reaction community I
have no comment on cuz I don't really
watch the reaction community not because
I think I'm better than anyone I just I
just don't you make so many reactions in
a day that you watch other stuff yeah I
don't like to keep a better eye on what
everybody else's I try to keep I try to
keep up with I try to keep up with doing
at least one to two videos a week that
are not reaction based that's why we did
the that's what I did they call me by
your name video Olivia yes John's in bed
with me right now because I'm sure
because I didn't want I can't like sit
oh I can barely get up I need a massage
come over I'm mister straight to the
point
I miss my straight to the front reviews
somebody really wants us to watch
shot-caller this has been a recurring
thing I wrote it down which Greg found
out John no homo I can't my girlfriend
just caught me on this live stream yeah
and if you really pound me then people
are actually gonna think we're good
DPG says I'm lazy Greg you lazy sick boy
yep
I'm totally lazy so lazy
I don't help run everything on YouTube
and patreon and work out five to six
days I don't do anything sit around all
day my jaw go do this for me that's all
I do V reactors you could collaborate
with other reactors who would you choose
oh for sure UV for sure I'm Dante and I
would love a reaction he did the best we
all said there I would love to bring
them on as guests and I do my thing and
they just keep the same face you guys
seen reaction to you time you guys gotta
go watch them there they did a reaction
funny a satire [ __ ] on reactions they
did a reaction to your reaction with cat
to the sketch we made I love it I was
actually wondering about them too I'm
thinking you know what they could have
done they might have just shot like one
or two for that to make them last for a
while and they're just laying any video
over yeah maybe it's possible red letter
media is when I favorite YouTube
channels every time they have a new
video and all I say I didn't start
getting into them until maybe a few
months ago but then past couple months I
kind of been through like a binge phase
of them I love the mr. plain to reviews
half and the bag is great that was I
counted that there were nerdy kids
what's that red letter media one called
nerd nerd nerd for the nerd group I was
so hilarious that was like scathing but
so funny Olivia asked if you could
choose a movie to describe your life
over to be Extremely Loud and Incredibly
Close I would choose
three billboards outside effing Missouri
a movie to describe my actually no
that's not funny when I put it like that
I thought it's the title just a title I
thought that was the question because
I'm we asked each other that question a
while ago if there was a title and I
totally read it wrong now
[Music]
like the context of the movie yeah Who
Framed Roger Rabbit Silicon Valley fan
fiction movie I'm gonna create Gregory
related Jessica Alba yes she's my
ancestral wife my number one favorite
movie Ferris Bueller's Day Off and
favorite no but I would probably go with
the matrix in this moment in time which
two characters are you most excited to
see Interactive Avengers infinity war
Hellboy and Martian man damn who's in
infinity war everyone Greg they're all
in it
let me look I want to see Stanley and I
want to see the entire Avengers just
have a scene with Sam Leone yeah we've
done wait wait where's V reacts comment
I do not wish Jessica Alba was my
ancestral sister
that would be so confusing V react says
yeah B you guys are hilarious
I would totally collaborate with you
guys I'm very organized and keep my word
okay we look to work with organized
people who say what they're gonna do in
do it you can only film a video reaction
with an or not his human being
what about JK films news whose JK not
sure o JK Simmons Jim
police station oh hey I started
searching superheroes confirmed and
before I even got through the the words
and I spelled them wrong for infinity
words the first autofill so lookie there
Angi Terpening the next Google hangout
y'all forgot me this past month we did
Terpening we gotta check that we just go
off of by like whatever is like says
people are like currently pledged at the
time or whatever but I should recheck
that list on my I made a mistake sorry
Angie Terpening Android surfing is
really trying to get me to read ready
player one right now I can't this goal
is to get me to read ready player one
after that he'll leave the real rejects
forever
you won't even check out our movie
review but I'm gonna kill it it's gonna
be great I really want to see Benedict
Wong and Cobie Smulders talk in the
infinity war I think those characters
yeah we cool most exciting all right
guys well my head's really hurting right
now so I'm wearing socks I feel I feel
off if Olivia there's a lot of comments
coming in if you can hear us that means
come over too late that means come over
Greg all right who's that you're
interrupting the lives you're on the
wife too that Olivia what's going on its
owner to come over I'm gonna put you on
speakerphone
rich reviews who's handsome here we go
guys I gotta take a phone call have you
guys seen jacksFilms reaction that she's
so funny
Olivia are you coming over oh yeah yeah
come on right now
oh maybe like a half-hour I gotta head
up some videos we'll never get off this
lives maybe I forgot I'm sorry my brains
not properly working well shower with
her clothes on and you'll get ready and
a half that's cool and you won't have to
wash those clothes later well we don't
talk about sex with my gay boyfriend
here I'm sorry guys I can leave
I'll just go tie right behind you
no John our guys I got a simple like one
or two more videos for tomorrow and then
I'm going to lay back down and I'll tell
you what I'm done you know one phone
calls on this live stream right now yeah
I only edit the reaction part though
that's the part that's actually multiple
takes cuz I die reshoot the reactions
how many people are taking a [ __ ] on
this stream we changed our names we
didn't change our names we just took off
our masks
when's the sex tape going to drop on
pornhub you know as soon as we're done
editing it it's a long time in iMovie
alright boyfriend boyfriend no John is
Jesus and Greg's Moses patron shaked
hey you enjoy that hookah Abdul puta you
enjoy yourself don't do anything I
wouldn't almost sub dog a cat whatever I
thought that's weird
John help me feed the cats do I want to
see a new Terminator movie not really
yeah let's do this
here we go here we go new Terminator
like kind of I like the game that
they're talking but at the same time
yeah they haven't gotten to write in a
while so my faith isn't high well I cut
my hair soon not a long way up but I'll
probably rein it in color it again
happens here we go why my cats behave
see they I can't find the other bullet I
lost it last night and I don't feel like
crawling around alright but here we go
guys they get them usually louder I
think their camera shot
[Music]
I'm sure this all-male audience is used
people love it
happy birthday Ramon Ramirez how's it
going how many olds are you today how
old is he
ana tell us I made some soup earlier
right happy birthday Ramon
all right guys love you I'll see you all
soon bye
cheerio all right well guys listen it's
been real brush your teeth stay hydrated
and remember could you and Greg do
reaction to my newest fan made trailer
oh goodness
well I'll take a look and see what we
can do now again what yeah I'm gonna
react to everything right now
oh man this is I've never been given
Greg's phone just to do what David Gandy
how's it going man good night
oh thanks please have the wettest of
dreams about us
happy birthday Brady jörgen son I'm glad
you're covered in feces there's a lot of
poop happening here and that's okay
whatever gets you off my number one
favorite movie is Ed Wood it's going
well tonight greg is sick
and I am NOT but you know I'm tired
show us my boobs all right that's that
that's enough of that all right that's
enough
that's all you get all right ps4 is
better than Xbox one maybe it's three
higher hunted despised
it's a pornhub casting couch twofer whoo
sorry this is just way too much fun I
knew it was you real skeleton I'm gonna
play you guys a song
all right goodbye Jango cocker spaniel
I'm gonna play you guys out this is how
we do it
thanks for tuning in to the live stream
I can't play that Radiohead song but
I'll learn it cold there buddy
goodbye Oh Olivier I'll do more live
streams Anna don't worry cuz I can
clearly pack people into a room all by
myself and as long as I got Greg to
laugh about
let's see okay so I'm in my room and
look all I got to do is is is peer out
that I can't door and there's Greg
there's a little Greggy just on the
other side hey you'll get one someday
you know that Dundee trailer has been
sitting on our desktop for so long I
don't know if we'll get through it or
not I hope so yeah I know there are
enough long haired people playing guitar
I'm sorry Russian propaganda but a good
job on our election thanks doc I'm glad
you appreciate it I would love to watch
the last man on earth you're adorable
sapphire L yeah no no go go go do you
chill from couch ugh where did Dan and
Elissa move to Narnia it's hard to get
to them because you can only find where
they live when you're not looking for it
so literally all I'm doing at the moment
is trying to make Greg laugh at the
computer rush is better than the USA eh
maybe I mean we're not doing great so a
lot of people are better than we are
right now uh North Korea I'm not gonna
touch this island uh I've heard the Jake
Gyllenhaal rumor I can see I don't I
don't know I I don't know who I want to
play Batman now yeah
ooh Abdul that's not a bad idea I mean
I'll try it's hard to come up with songs
correct it's better coming up with songs
and I'm good at coming up with like
parts so you know paint me like what if
your blinker you can be a king or a
little street sweeper but sooner or
later you'll dance with the reaper it's
good I like that movie i won
I got that movie in a box of pizza years
ago when Pizza Hut did that promotion
Ryan Gosling Batman it would be it would
be cool I don't think it would it would
work out I feel like he'd be a better
like Nightwing or something but Greg
could tell you more about that Jon Hamm
uh-uh yeah he'd be a good Batman I wish
he could have been a Superman what a
Greg gets you for your birthday well let
me tell you all right he got you a
stripper cake but we accidentally cooked
it with the stripper in it so that's a
problem it's a mess and so you're
probably just gonna get like a handmade
card of some kind you know crayons
old-school Uganda but we're gonna make a
life reaction the Oscars no I don't
think so we tried that once and it was
not as fun as it could have been but who
knows maybe in the future when we have a
better way of doing it okay Joseph Dell
we'll think about I would like to see
the Dundee trailers so either way I'll
react to it if we don't
I think Greg's like in the flash seems
like he's got a sexually got a bunch of
like full-length episode reactions up so
if you want to know his thoughts on the
flash go check that [ __ ] out or come
over to patreon where they're uncut and
uncensored balls out new Cloverfield
movie straight to Netflix have not heard
about that all right all right I'll do
consider putting up some of the covers
if anybody likes them they're just my
way of like practicing and getting
better but um I I consider that I'd be
done oh yeah no it's okay we'll get you
an intact stripper I promise
who would play you and Greg and the
other rejects in a movie about the real
rejects all right Adam driver would play
Greg and then let's see the guy who
plays Ron Swanson will play me and we'll
go from there there's a new rampage
trailer oh boy yeah can't wait for san
andreas with videogame characters
there's a thong in my cave I have not
heard anything about these new
Cloverfield movies that's a god particle
is supposed to be the new Cloverfield
but apparently not um or maybe I just
haven't heard any more news well
everything is more sexy than trumpets no
saying much that guy is not fit no
matter what that test says oh god
particle is going to Netflix that's cool
favorite Cartoon Network shows um
cartoons I don't know like Adult Swim
stuff like Rick and Morty or Venture
Brothers or or uh Adventure Time or
Steven universe on Cartoon Network
I like Steven universe hmm what do you
think will happen in the relationship
between ray and been stolen episode nine
well I think they're pretty rifted now I
would love for Anita to play me I think
that would be a major upgrade from real
life and she's a good actress too like
when we shot that sketch you know we
were all like we hadn't seen her act
before but I was like wow you're a
natural
well then really I got you into Ricky
Morty that's an honor thanks dude
I'm glad you're diggin it I
it's one of my favorite shows for sure
some smart writing and some crazy [ __ ]
on there Cloverfield station a hmm okay
I'll wait I'm down new Jurassic world
will probably only be scary an IMAX not
at home well yeah I believe that it
doesn't look like it's trying to be
super scary it looks like it's trying to
be over-the-top and fun what's my
favorite movie Ed Wood what's up I'm
live streaming did I ever listen to that
song by allagash al Allen still trying
to pronounce that name but yes I did
alla gosh Alec [ __ ] yes Agalloch egg
awash yeah yes I did though very
cinematic right I'm thinking back I'm
trying to remember it's been a little
while but this that sort of cinematic
metal music yeah I dug it fair Adult
Swim show right now is Rick and Morty
for sure hey if anybody wants Steven
universe reactions like if people
actually wanted them I would do a couple
for patreon sure that's a show that I've
seen like scattershot episodes for but
not you know a ton I've never seen
supernatural I've been told Greg is
editing he's over there there he is you
see him hold on can i zoom can i zoom
there he is look at him look at him oh
yeah no I I'm glad you're enjoying it I
actually I just I had a lot of people I
I know we're recommending it to me and I
do like a lot of different kinds of
shows so I I'm that's not fake at all
I'm really enjoying Riverdale and
sometimes it's hard to wait until
there's time to shoot one of those
episodes before watching another one so
so yeah I mean it's a bit different for
what I usually get around to watching
but um you know I try to kind of be
opened everything because anything is
compelling and the more broad stuff that
you watch you know the more outside your
wheelhouse stuff you watch the better
your own creativity gets so do you guys
want to watch the Han Solo movie not
really not looking forward to that I did
not really want that I do like metal I'm
picky about it though
but I like some metal it depends I like
Mastodon a lot I mean these are more
novelty acts but I love like Rob Zombie
and Powerman 5000 there are better
examples that I'm naming now but yeah I
can get down with some metal for sure it
just depends on I like I guess
progressive more melodic metal or metal
that involves melody and not just just
an instance and screaming or whatever
but yeah I get down with some metal for
sure I get down with every kind of music
at some point I have never watched a
full episode of Tim and Eric it really
creeps me out but I feel like I ought to
my favorite horror movies like the
original Texas Chainsaw the thing how
many burgers doing a munch not really
many anymore I used to eat a lot now
Iron Man is pretty good have favorite
horror I got a I got a like compiled
list but Shaun of the Dead you know
there